this video is brought to you by remote
hq the platform that allows teams to
work together as if they were in the
same room even when they're not
hey welcome back to new rockstars i'm
phil molina and this is tommy bechtold
what do you brought me she brought me
beer tell me i've got some bite-sized
questions for you a little
ah should i i'm ready thank you
uh all right first question i have for
you this question came from us on
twitter too you can see uh on screen who
it came from
uh it's a very specific scenario it's
what would happen to the food
that is inside of ant-man's stomach
when he grows all big-like and then
this person wanted to know will he take
a giant dump
yeah i mean short answer is hell yeah he
will
uh this is again though some science
that we can actually pull upon based on
what works
has been explained in comics in movies
in the first ant-man hank pym
explains that what the pin particles do
is they actually
increase or decrease the distance
between atoms so when he's getting
bigger
the atomic distance is just like it's
just increasing so everything's getting
stretched out but there's no
more he's not getting additional atoms
so the mass is the same yes exactly
if ant-man were to eat a tiny crumb when
he's little if ant-man's this tall
that crumb would grow with the size of
ant-man but it would still only have the
same nutritional value as that tiny
crumb so whatever
state he's in whatever the size or
whatever the food he's ingesting then it
maintains that same nutritional
properties
now when humans excrete waste it doesn't
matter i mean like obviously the
different things that you eat
will impact like you know how you get
rid of waste but like
presumably if he has a giant crumb in
his stomach he's going to have to get
that out of his system so
that would be a big dump i hate to be
crass but this is the question listen i
didn't ask it i know it's gross it's
science
so yeah big man big dumps as mean dean
oakland said in
the andre the giant documentary i wish
we could snip that out and just put that
on your like business card
big man big jokes so yeah so like the
polite thing for him to do would be to
get sub-atomic it's super small and then
uh do a little shoot that little poop
out there
any of us would do that if i had that
option of just like shrinking down could
you imagine
just like give me a second did you just
take a dump in the office no no no no no
no no no
it smells a little bad it's like ant-man
meets curb your enthusiasm
larry where did you go nowhere oh man i
got a tiny little smear on my
jacket now if he becomes giant man
and then and then like it breaks over
and he goes and takes one does he take a
little normal one that falls out or does
he take a giant where i'm confused
if he's giant man at the time does it it
would be a mask also
yeah so it's like a city block yeah it
would be you know like
uh like a comet heading towards earth
because he throws it
yeah gross thomas yeah that is
disgusting and i apologize
next bite size question yes not only um
where luke's lightsaber is right now in
the narrative star wars
but also kind of just like what's the
path of that whole thing been
where what journey has it been on well i
actually have luke skywalker's
lightsaber in my on my bookshelf
naturally yes uh because at comic con in
2015 there was a concert
by john williams where everyone got
lightsabers and i ended up
being snuck into a party by a security
guard that the cast of force awakens was
with mark hamill there and he left his
lightsaber behind it i stole it so
what mark if you want it back i got your
lightsaber no this is
this is it on the psychopath test you
lied about being like a thief
you also said you were a liar bing bang
boom huh i'm not anything i didn't say i
was well you take big dumps well i think
big dumps i buy drugs from babies and i
got mark hamill's lightsaber
put it on my gravestone i steal from
mark hamill that's the one that he
brought
no no no he got so he left it there and
i waited a solid amount of time before i
took it
but he left it there and then left the
party and it was like a little souvenir
they got at the end of the concert
so i have no way of proving this like i
could show you a green it's a toy
lightsaber it's like a plastic little
collapsible thing i could just tell you
that that was that and you would have to
either believe me which would be a
mistake or trust me i've learned okay so
anyway neither version of this is good
for you now that i've name dropped and
just told a story that's basically
bragging about my life we have a sweet
life
but that is not a positive story about
you do i cheat and steal
no it's a cool souvenir it's a cool star
wars souvenir that i stole without any
australian accent sucks i take our
thanks to that
that's not bad thank you okay now for
the real answer so in the movie let's
track
the lightsabers progression it first
leaves its original owner anakin
skywalker on mustafar during his battle
with obi-wan kenobi slicey slicey
lightsaber goes somewhere obi-wan takes
it brings it into
onto tatooine where it hides with him
for about 20 years and keeps
that thing and then uh luke puts his eye
on it yeah yeah he looks it real close
uh so until luke skywalker comes and
obi-wan
gives it to luke now luke then uses that
lightsaber to battle his father darth
vader formerly anakin skywalker
until anakin in a roll reversal slices
luke's arm off
again it's like poetry so if they rhyme
right about here
and the lightsaber tumbles into a vent
on cloud
cloud city so at that point
it's a little murky but from the actual
star wars site the actual starwars.com
site it said that a scavenger
picked up the lightsaber chilling on a
cloud just hanging out
it's like one of those cloud koopas from
mario fishes it out with his fishing
pole
no uh a scavenger picks it up and then
sells it to maz kanata
who's known to collect jedi artifacts
and curiosities so
maz kanata's planet is called takadon
takadona is near bespin cloud city so it
wouldn't make sense that that would come
across her desk
she's like a collector she has she's got
money flags of the pod races
so she's you know it's like it's like a
big player in the antique market like
obviously someone who has a lightsaber
is going to keep trying to bring it
there to get the most money well she
also is force sensitive too so maybe she
like maybe
you could call out to her yeah
absolutely so then when han
rey finn and uh and and the gang
go to see maz kanata the lightsaber
calls out to rey but if you remember she
initially rejects it so for a brief time
it's wielded by
finn who we learn in rise of skywalker
is force sensitive but we don't get to
pursue that very much because it just
wasn't sexy enough for disney
just kidding we can cut that so then rey
does the right thing he returns it to
luke skywalker and octo and he does the
respectful appropriate gracious thing
and throws it off a cliff
to be fair he was trying to get rid of
it at cloud city that's true he's been
trying to ditch that thing for a while
he doesn't like to have his dad's things
so then
rey herself banishes herself to octo
after
in the events of rise of skywalker where
she meets luke's force ghost who then
returns that lightsaber and also
leia's lightsaber right and that's the
two lightsabers that
ben solo and ray use to defeat the
emperor and then rey
buries it in the sand where we presume
it'll stay forever and definitely won't
be found by jawas whose entire life and
ecosystem or
not ecosystem economy is based on
scavenging and finding relics and
selling them for trade
they're also like this deep aren't they
yeah they're like they're like a foot
and a half deep
wind yeah wind may uncover them as well
or that old lady that said what's your
last name
yeah i saw what you put in there they're
very nosy were those lightsabers
what's your last name uh great yep all
right so and that's where they are
as of right now so as of right now
they're in the sands of tatooine and if
it's mark hamill's
it's one two three candy cane that's
right and i
i live with eric voss in an inflatable
house and a bounce castle on yeah
and again thank you to remote hq for
sponsoring this video remote hq is a
high security collaborative workspace
that lets remote teams work together in
ways that aren't possible with other
tools they let you and your team work
together as if you're in the same room
even when everyone is at home
or in a van with really good wi-fi i
really want to be one of those guys so
the remote hq platform is browser-based
so there is nothing to download the
feature we really love at new rockstars
is that the workspace is customizable
and you can mix and match apps for
any use like we can play a youtube video
and open chrome or dropbox and then edit
a google doc
all while we are in the process of
talking with each other remote hq
automatically captures and logs notes
from
every event into a searchable trail so
when off-screen producer zach and i get
into an argument about whether he
actually met don cheadle or not
i could just easily search through the
notes of our friday meeting and see that
he
in fact did not boom are you looking for
this i found it head to remotehq.com
new rockstars for a free trial and when
you're ready to launch
use the code new rockstars for three
months for free that is code new
rockstars for three months free at
remotehq.com
new rockstars next bite size question
yes yum yum yum who
is faster in a foot race
me or you oh no i'm kidding
it's gonna be close it's closed yeah
it's close if i
if you elaine well in this scenario
there's clones of each other you're
carrying my clone on your back
and i'm carrying your clone and it's a
dead heat we're both
who's faster in a foot race captain
america
or black panther yeah good old steve raj
and t'challa
yes yes uh this one is a very
fascinating question
and it basically boils down to my
pleasure my treasure uh
do you take scientific data or do you
take the old eye test
because we've got both comic book and
visual media to
support our our facts here so in the
movie captain america winter soldiers
explained that captain america ran
13 miles in 30 minutes it was a 25
second mile
for those of us not uh i could do the
math so based on that that would mean he
could reach a top speed of 120 miles an
hour hopefully
that's said in the movie now in the
comics 120 miles per hour
what else goes 120 miles per hour a
ferrari i think maybe a lamborghini
so in the comics it's only ever been
stated that he can run up to 60 miles an
hour so those are cold hard written down
or at least put on film facts so 60 or
120 or 120
still very fast uh based on that speed
that means his 100
meter dash would be 1.52 seconds now to
put that in perspective the fastest 100
meter dash
in the real world is usain bolt in 2009
ran it in 9.8
so that is yeah that's a full eight
seconds shorter than that
okay so that's the difference between z
and
hm like that dude that makes sense did
that translate
i related about that i am
this is what a psychopath would do uh
anyway so we have that written down but
when we see the movie captain america
civil war
black panther easily runs past captain
america when they're both
in a full sprint and he's running past
cars now we can take
the scientific footage and and knowing
where the movie was shot and where it
was supposed to be
speed limit in that area is roughly 30
miles an hour so it's like 50 kilometers
an hour so the cars if we even say that
they're all moving
at the speed limit which would be 30
miles an hour the speed with which black
panther runs from the end of one car to
the front of it while it's in motion
is super super fast he does it in under
a second so we can calculate he's moving
somewhere around 40 miles an hour
so based on their maximum sprinting
speed captain america's is about 60.
t'challa's is about 38 miles an hour 40
miles an hour so
based on their their uh their top mphs
they're top miles per hour you would say
captain america
but in that in the movie the eye test
black panther clearly runs faster than
captain america and if we're just taking
the movie logic that would mean that
black panther can run faster than 120
miles an hour
at his top speed which feels like he
does at least in the end
yeah absolutely so i guess it's just you
gotta it's the old
eye test versus data like you keep
saying the old but what are you
referencing
you know like people say like i see like
people who believe things that only
believe literally things that they've
seen before
but like when like your doctor gives you
like your blood test results you're like
well my eyes don't see
yeah i don't see i just see i see the
blood working fine well i can see the
blood pouring all around no further
questions
no i guess yeah you know i guess it just
depends i mean it appears as though
in the movies t'challa is definitely
faster based on what we have
in the comic books captain america is
faster and so maybe cap wasn't running
full sprint
yeah i'm guessing because you have to
take in that scene
kept protecting bucky barnes they're
being chased humans chase after an
object they can they can achieve
superhuman speech pursuing something
and based on observations in nature when
when creatures are being chased by uh by
predators when like
like a a rodent is being chased by a
hawk that wrote it will run faster than
what's expected or
what has been you know they'll have
supernatural speeds and abilities being
chased so
and what's interesting is you did that
research before we asked this question
that's true i just knew this
the psychopath i've been thinking about
chasing people i don't know new year new
me i'm going to be a chase
yeah are you able to see that
combination of what you've learned about
yourself i like to chase people and it
appears i'll be faster when i do it and
the idea of being harder faster
stronger is better for me no one said
harder i did
i did oh gosh i hate it hey good job you
answered the question
thank you and they were researched i'm
proud of you you feel great about it and
they're all honest and i would never lie
and lying isn't a thing that i like to
do
make sure to listen to big question as a
podcast too you can
download the podcast everywhere you get
those uh and make sure to just follow
the channel everywhere
on twitter and uh on instagram and
whatnot you can find out what videos are
coming out when
uh and then also make sure to follow
tommy bechdel where we can find you
you can find me on all platforms at
tommy beck told
wow and i'm philip molina you can find
me at philippelleno on instagram and on
twitter
uh but definitely make sure to mail us
at the mailbag and send in your
questions and
sometime soon we'll get drunk and share
too much information about your question
see ya cheers bye
[Music]
you